let's say for example you went 2 weeks
with less than 5 hours of sleep each
night what would actually happen now
some of you watching do get 5 hours of
sleep or maybe 6 hours of sleep but you
don't get seven or eight hours of sleep
so some of these symptoms I'm going to
talk about uh can affect you but more on
a moderate or mild basis but what you
need to know is there's a huge huge
consequence of not getting enough rest I
remember as a kid I slept so good I
would get 9 hours of sleep and then I
got a little bit older and went through
basic training and I was R awakened at
4:00 in the morning well ever since then
I tend to get up at 4:00 and that's why
I go to bed a little bit earlier to try
to get that seven hours so I've had a
really long history of poor sleep to the
extreme where some nights I didn't even
sleep 1 minute I laid there the entire
night torture so ideally getting 7 to 8
hours to sleep is super healthy I looked
at some research on this uh 35 years ago
the average US adult slept 7.7 hours
which nowadays it's significantly less I
mean even if we compare 20 years ago uh
to now there's way more people getting
less than 6 hours of sleep than just 20
years ago as a nation or even the world
we're just getting less and less sleep
so let's go through all the consequences
of not getting enough sleep especially
if you're not getting at least five
hours of sleep okay first of all why do
we need rest in the first place right
well that's when a lot of things recover
that's when our muscles recover that's
when we burn the most fat that is when
our bodies do the most
detoxification that's when our brains
detox and so this is why when you don't
get enough sleep you're going to feel
kind of toxic especially in your head so
the first problem you're going to run
into if you're not getting enough sleep
is fatigue or what they call daytime
sleepiness and there's nothing worse
than driving when you're tired right
especially long road trips and you're
just like dosing off the at the road
that could be very very dangerous there
are significant mood changes when you
don't get enough sleep way more than
other types of cognitive problems like
memory attention and loss of focus your
mood will probably be one of the biggest
things that will change you're no longer
going to be happy and and upbeat you're
going to be a bit depressed agitated and
irritated now thinking about that can
you imagine how many people are put on
psych drugs when really they just need a
good night's rest the next thing I want
to mention is the cognitive function
mainly memory focus and concentration so
if you are a student right trying to
study or you're someone that has to
focus on some type of creativity let's
say you're a writer or you have to come
up with content or you're a content
creator like myself boy being tired just
shuts that right down and so this is why
I like the brain booster industry
all these different pills that people
take you know caffeine to try to
stimulate their their mental capacities
to help them Focus not to mention drugs
as well unfortunately that's treating
the symptom and not the cause and that's
why the person always gets worse very
interesting study which I'll put down
below involving 3,000 students who all
got poor sleep well actually less than 6
hours there were mood changes there were
Behavior changes there was an increased
desire for alcohol there were
self-esteem issues
there were decreased ability to learn
even on top of that there was an
increased elevation of a suicide risk
the other thing that happens when you
don't get enough sleep is you have
something called
sympathetic hyperactivity there's a part
of the nervous system called the
sympathetic nervous system and that
system is in overdrive when you're not
sleeping so you're going to have more
adrenaline you're going to have more
cortisol because your adrenals are
revved up and so yes it is true that
having an overactive sympathetic nervous
system or a stressed out or overactive
adrenal can keep you up but also not
getting enough sleep can then cause the
adrenals and the stress and the
sympathetics to kick in the sympathetic
nervous system is kind of like the
accelerator of the nervous system and
you're not going to be able to sleep if
it's accelerated and so it's the other
system that kind of puts the brakes on
this flat or fight mechanism that's
called the parasympathetic both of these
syst systems can be measured and um I
may or may not have uh information on
this when you're looking down below
searching for it in the description but
I will very soon there's a great tool
that you can actually visualize this
part of the nervous system and see where
you're at you can look at your stress
and you can also look at your ability to
recover and many other aspects related
to that like should you really be
working out today or not maybe you
should be walking because if you're not
sleeping and you're Sy athetic overdrive
or
hyperactive you should not be uh
exercising of any type of high intensity
at all you should be walking because
it's going to put more strain on your
heart so this sympathetic overdrive
especially if it's chronic okay it goes
on for weeks and weeks and weeks Beyond
just two weeks but might go on for
months or years really put stress on
your heart you're going to be at risk
for cardiovascular problems at risk for
a stress broke at risk for being a
diabetic why because cortisol and
adrenaline releases sugar which then
increases insulin despite not eating any
sugar your sugar levels will be higher
because even the name of the adrenal
hormones another name for cortisol is
glucocorticoids because it regulates
glucose so this is why you have
impairments with your glucose and uh
problems with your blood sugars and
insulin which then relate to weight gain
in a fatty liver the other very unique
thing that happens with that cortisol
being elevated is your immune system
shuts down it becomes paralyzed when you
have higher levels of cortisol you have
this lessening of the white blood cells
they don't work this is why all of these
um conditions that involve autoimmune
problems right where you have these
antibodies attacking your own tissues or
even
people with um certain skin problems
allergies or inflammatory conditions
because it's an overactive immune system
the general treatment is steroids what's
a steroid cortisone because cortisone is
anti-inflammatory but it's also an
immune supressant if you can't sleep
right you're getting less than five
hours and you have this sympathetic
overdrive and you're trying to lose
weight good luck it's not going to
happen in fact you can work with someone
on their diet but boy if the sleep is
not right and they're also exercising at
the same time you're just wasting your
time getting someone into a wonderful
rejuvenating sleep that can create huge
changes in weight loss the next thing
getting less than 5 hours of sleep will
impair your recovery I'm talking about
recovery from an injury recovery from
stress and recovery from
exercise so most of the recovery if not
all the recovery from exercise occurs
when you are sleeping if you are
sleeping and so if you're exercising and
not sleeping you're not going to see the
benefit of the exercise you break down
the body and you keep breaking it down
but you never recover then you exercise
over that you'll have a lot of issues so
the rule of thumb is don't ever do
high-intensity exercise when you haven't
slept and when you have poor recovery
you're not going to adapt and benefit
from that exercise but you can do
walking all right the next thing I want
to talk about is sleep apnea because
this also falls in this same area where
the person is just not getting enough
oxygen when they're sleeping and that's
why they have to use a CPAP machine to
uh blow oxygen or sometimes just air
into their upper respiratory in their
lungs and this also includes a lot of
people who uh have heavy snoring and
that creates something called hypoxia
okay that's just a lack of oxygen and
anytime you have a lack of oxygen you
also might have an extra increase of Co
to so not enough oxygen is bad too much
CO2 is bad it can be toxic so you need
the balance of both you you don't want
all oxygen either you want some CO2 to
allow that oxygen to penetrate deep into
the cells but you need the right balance
but when you have like sleep apnea and
you're obstructing air going into your
body especially when you're sleeping it
can create even more severe uh problems
with your body like brain atrophy the
frontal cortex actually atrophies and
shrinks in people with bad sleep apnea
because you're depriving the brain of
oxygen when you're sleeping you also can
develop an increased risk of cancer and
cardiovascular incidents and as well as
strokes and diabetes so there are many
things you can do for sleep apnea I have
those in a lot of different videos which
I will put down below just for people
who don't get enough sleep the most
effective treatment for that right off
the bat is taking a nap okay just taking
a nap or just trying to lay there until
you hopefully fall asleep to get some
more sleep a couple more tips on this
topic you want to keep your uh room on
the cool side between 60 and
65° maybe up to 68° but keep it cool if
you can keep your window open you'll
sleep a little bit better but having a
room that's real stuffy and hot is not a
good thing if you're humidity in the
room is like 50% you'll find that that
would be the optimum humidity for for
the best sleep another really important
thing is to turn off all the electronics
in your room especially next to your
head when you're sleeping why because
this EMF wave stands for electromagnetic
fields okay and magnetic fields um
really affect the brain waves in the
heart and that can affect your quality
of sleep big time it did for me in fact
I found the wires in the wall and back
of my bed were crossed and that was
creating an electromagnetic field that
extended 8 ft from the wall so I was
being bathed in this magnet energy that
just was not good for my heart I started
getting heart palpitations and I
eventually figured out what it was and
when I had the electrician fix it all of
those symptoms just magically
disappeared another really important
thing is um the quantity of food that
you eat especially in the evening okay
if you do too much you're not going to
sleep that well because because when
you're bloated that affects your
sleeping up here so you don't want to
overeat and then you also don't want to
undereat some people that don't consume
enough protein or the right amount um
they can also have a hard time getting
asleep staying asleep or waking up and
feeling refreshed so I think the key is
to play around with the amount of
protein that you need and I would guess
that would be anywhere between like 3
and 1/2 to 7 o of protein for that
dinner depending on a lot of different
variables you know your size your your
age your activity level your ability to
digest that protein and it's best not to
eat uh too late it's best to eat earlier
okay you're going to find you're going
to sleep better if you can not have a
lot of uh stuff going on with the
digestive system and the other thing is
as it starts to get darker and let's say
6 7 o' start dimming the lights wherever
you are at try not to sit in front of a
computer screen because that blue light
especially the artificial lights can
interfere with the whole mechanism of um
the light going into the retina which
then goes through a whole Cascade of
things that increases your melatonin
Darkness triggers melatonin light
decreases melatonin melatonin helps you
sleep so it's best that you tone down
the light in the evening now because of
the sensoring and the suppressing of the
algorithm on YouTube it's becoming more
difficult to find my content and there's
a lot of content that I cannot put on
YouTube unfortunately so to make sure
you have full access of all my
information go to drberg.com And
subscribe to my newsletter by clicking
the link Down Below in the description I
will see you on the other
side